1284 erdähnliche planeten gefunden
eine zweite haut für den menschen und
ein weiterer erfolg für space extra sind
drei der fünf themen in den aktuellen
klick zum top news wann und wie kam der
sauerstoff auf die erde forscher der
monash university in melbourne haben
neues über den sauerstoffgehalt der erde
heraus gefunden ursprünglich ist man
davon ausgegangen dass für etwa drei
milliarden jahren wenig bis gar kein
sauerstoff in der erdatmosphäre
vorhanden war
jetzt konnte diese theorie widerlegt
werden bei der analyse von winzigen
meteoriten sogenannten mikrometeoriten
konnten sie spuren von oxidiertem eisen
finden bei dieser oxidation sei eine
ähnlich hohe sauerstoffkonzentration wie
jetzt hier auf der erde nötig gewesen
also das bisherige wissen wurde komplett
auf den kopf gestellt wie matthew gang
vom imperial college london erklärt war
als zitat eine überraschung war es als
gesichert gilt dass zumindest die unter
erdatmosphäre vor 2 7 milliarden jahren
sehr sauerstoff arm war
zitat ende mit den neuen erkenntnissen
könne man im besagten forschungsgebiet
große erfolge erzielen gänge weiter
der nächste schritt bei unserer
forschung wird sein mikrometeoriten aus
einer reihe von felsen zu extrahieren
die eine milliarde jahre der
erdgeschichte abdecken wir werden uns
vor allem auf die große ob situations
phase konzentrieren sie vor 24
milliarden jahren einsetzte als es zu
einem plötzlichen sprung bei den
sauerstoffkonzentrationen in der unteren
atmosphäre kam zitat ende
die frage wann genau und vor allem wie
sauerstoff auf die erde kam könnte dann
endgültig geklärt werden hyper luke
erfolg in der theorie klingt das prinzip
des hyper lux sensationell
man würde dies zunächst einmal einen
tunnel der dazu reichen ist darin ein
teil vakuum zu erzeugen
dafür sorgen pumpen die die luft
absaugen dadurch verringert sich der
luftwiderstand für die transport kapseln
das spart energie
die wände des tunnels bestehen aus bis
zu 25 mm dickem stahl es soll
verschiedene kapseln geben für personen
und für lassen so viel zur theorie nach
las vegas setzte das unternehmen hyper
lupe
ihre theorie jetzt in die praxis
zwar nicht zu 100 prozent denn einen
tunnel gab es nicht und die theoretische
geschwindigkeit von 1200 kilometern pro
stunde konnte auch noch nicht umgesetzt
werden aber der testwagen erreichte auf
100 metern immerhin eine geschwindigkeit
von 600 kilometern pro stunde in vier
jahren soll das fertige transport wunder
600 kilometer in einer halben stunde ab
waren übrigens haben wir zur ganzen
dahinter steckenden technologie ein
ausführliches video gemacht den link
findet ihr in der video beschreibung
weiterer erfolg für spacex nachdem
kürzlich gefeierten land erfolg der
falcon 9 rakete auf der landeplattform
im atlantik das private
raumfahrtunternehmen nun einen weiteren
grund zu feiern eine trägerrakete konnte
sowohl sicher gestartet als auch wieder
gelandet werden wir haben euch die erste
landung gezeigt also wollen wir euch
auch die zweite nicht vorenthalten
viel spaß
1284 exoplaneten entdeckt erst vor einer
woche haben wir ja von drei exoplaneten
berichte die der erde sehr ähnlich sein
könnten
nasa-wissenschaftler jetzt mit dem
kepler weltraumteleskop 1284 weitere exo
planeten gefunden zitat das bestärkt
unsere hoffnung dass es irgendwo da
draußen einen stern geben muss der
unserem ähnelt wir könnten letztlich
eine andere erde entdecken so allen
stoffen 9 der 1284 exo planeten bewegen
sich übrigens in einer mit unserer erde
vergleichbaren umlaufbahn um eine sonne
der fund der 1284 erdähnliche planeten
ist eine absolute sensation immer mehr
exoplaneten werden in immer kürzerer
zeit entdeckt und mit dem jetzigen fund
haben wir jetzt insgesamt 3.200
exoplaneten entdeckt zitat dank keppler
und der forschergemeinschaft wissen wir
jetzt dass es mehr planeten als sterne
geben könnte mit diesem wissen können
wir zukünftige missionen ausstatten mit
denen wir vielleicht herausfinden ob wir
allein in diesem universum sind so paul
hertz von der nasa der fund peitscht
also die forschung voran und wirft eine
alte frage auf sind wir allein die
zweite haut forschern des massachusetts
institute of technology kurz mrt ist
sensationell es gelungen sie haben eine
zweite haut für den menschlichen körper
erschaffen schwierig daran die haut
nachzubauen sind ihre besonderen
eigenschaften kaum ein material kann die
elastizität und beschaffenheit der haut
nachahmen diese neue haut besteht aus
polymeren aus silizium und sauerstoff
sie kann um 250 gedehnt werden ohne dass
beim erschaffen schäden oder
dehnungsstreifen zurück bleiben unsere
natürliche haut kann man gerade mal um
180% denen ohne dass man sichtbare
folgen davontragen muss für was aber
soll diese 2000 gut sein im fachmagazin
nature materials erklären die forscher
zitat es ist eine durchsichtige schicht
die kosmetische verbesserungen schafft
eine barriere bildet und möglicherweise
medikamente lokal an stellen abgeben
könnte die behandelt werden sollen diese
drei aspekte schaffen viel
versprechendes potenzial für den einsatz
beim menschen
zitat ende das was die forscher in ihrer
studie nennen ist aber eben erst der
anfang einer weitreichenden forschung
wozu könnte diese zweite haut noch so
gut sein wo kann man sie überall
einsetzen lasst uns über die
verschiedenen einsatzbereiche in den
kommentaren diskutieren ich bin auf eure
vorschläge gespannt und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat bitte lasst einen
daumen nach oben da abonniert klick zum
kostenlos und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran